welcome
and thank you for joining us today
we're going to be speaking about how to
build event-driven applications on
google cloud using eventark
my name is brian zimmerman product
manager at google cloud focusing on
eventark
and my name is matatamel i'm a developer
advocate at google cloud
before getting into the details
let's look at our orchestration suite of
products at a high level
today as we're talking about building
event driven applications event arc is
the product that helps you accomplish
this easily
along with workflows tasks and scheduler
event arc is part of a suite of products
that are fully managed flexible and
enterprise ready to help you accomplish
all of your orchestration needs
eventark connects to over 60 gcp
services through its integration with
cloud auto logs
in addition our integration with pub sub
as a source
allows you to use event arc for events
raised from your own application
as far as targets we currently support
cloud run in ga
and cloud run for anthos and functions
in preview
our other products support even more
targets through http execution
together these fully managed and
flexible products help developers
connect the cloud with less code
in our demo today you will see many of
these products in action specifically
event arc workflows cloud run and cloud
functions
so what do we mean by event driven
architecture
first let's talk about the modern
application
here's an example of a simple
application with a complex web of
service teams working together towards a
common goal
this application is somewhat complicated
with interactions and dependencies that
can become a dragon velocity
but in reality today your application is
more likely to look like this an
extremely complex web of point-to-point
interactions creating a significant
number of dependencies and points of
failure
as applications expand horizontally
connections become even more complex and
difficult to understand
while microservice patterns provide a
great deal of advantages
they also come with a great deal of
complexity
by contrast event-driven architecture
produces a solution for this problem it
provides the ability to reduce
dependencies and complexity in your
application while still allowing the
creation of more and more microservices
event-driven architecture allows true
separation of concern
a producer need not know how an event
will be consumed or take on any
dependency from a downstream service
similarly the consumer only needs to
know that the event will be raised and
understand how to utilize it none of the
details of the upstream service
with this loosely coupled approach we
eliminate hard dependencies between
services
and eliminate that drag on velocity
in a traditional application
you can only scale one way vertically
with event driven architecture a
developer is easily able to scale an
application as performance needs
increase
furthermore
imagine a scenario where you're adding a
new service to an existing application
in a point-to-point signaling model
upstream services must be updated in
order to signal the downstream services
however in an event-driven pattern
users are easily able to add a new
service from existing events without
updating the upstream application at all
this helps to eliminate that spider web
of concerns and point-to-point
interactions substantially
event arc is google's solution to this
problem it is a managed eventing system
that makes building event driven
serverless applications easy
simply select the google cloud service
or pub sub topic you're interested in as
a source
define the filter parameters
and choose the target you wish to invoke
we do use pub sub in the background as a
transport layer to benefit from its
superior reliability and observability
but we take care of all the details of
setup
simply create that trigger and we'll
take care of the event ingress the
filtering and the delivery of events to
your desired target
lastly
we use the cncf standard cloud events
format and because of this it's easy to
understand and unmarshal the details of
your events
in order to more
intelligently drive application behavior
now i'd like to share an important
customer story from one of our customers
vivint
vivint is an exciting iot company
they currently power the smart home for
over 1.8 million customers
their portfolio of devices is impressive
offering smart home bundles that cover
everything from cameras to locks to
important sensors such as flood sensors
as these devices are important for
ensuring your home is running smoothly
and safely latency and reliability of
the back-end system is extremely
important for creating the right
customer experience
let's talk a bit about the challenge
they were facing
in 2020 vivint was presented with an
exciting business opportunity they
intended to offer a standalone doorbell
camera outside of their smart home
bundle this was an interesting technical
challenge their core system you see was
built around the concept of bundles so
this standalone offering was a
significant departure from that model
lastly time to market really mattered
there was a limited window they had in
which to make this happen in order to
address this fast-moving market segment
here's what they built
by leveraging events and serverless
technology they were able to separate
the components needed to run the camera
application from the core platform
without having to rewrite everything
and without adding any any risk or
instability to the user experience of
either the new application or their core
offering
let's examine in detail the architecture
used for their use case
or one of their use cases specifically
an image processing pipeline for their
camera application
images were loaded from the camera to a
gcs bucket
this invoked a cloud function or cloud
run for antho service which analyzed the
images using the computer vision api in
order to categorize and annotate
appropriately
the results were updated in a bigquery
data set for use later
and the front-end platform was signaled
via an integration with pub sub
firebase fcm was used in order to send
notifications to the mobile app
and their core platform received the
event for historical reasons and
tracking
the result
eventark and gcp serverless technology
allowed them to accelerate time to value
and time to market
not only did these products help solve
their problem but did so in a way that
would scale
and by achieving separation of concern
without risking their core technology
to dig into some of the secondary
benefits this provided a number of
things that were really interesting to
them
first it decreased time to market as i
mentioned the back-end system was
developed and ready to go earlier than
expected
they were also able to implement
continuous deployment they deployed new
code after every two-week sprint this is
an improvement over the previous
quarterly ota updates
by using event processing in the same
location they were also able to sorry in
the same location as the notification
service they were also able to decrease
latency by 78 percent
and finally
built entirely on managed serverless and
orchestration products the new solution
was scalable even in the most successful
scenarios
vivint didn't have to worry about
scalability out of the gate as they were
able to rest assured in the confidence
of google cloud's ability to scale
hopefully vivint's story helps exemplify
how eventark and google cloud can help
accelerate time to value for your
organization
to help understand how this can work for
you in the real world meche has created
a demo of a similar image processing
pipeline
so with this said i will hand things
over to
thanks brian
i'll show you a simplified image
processing pipeline
in this pipeline users drop images in a
cloud storage bucket
these images will be processed by a
chain of cloud run and cloud function
services we use event arc to trigger the
pipeline via cloud run
and workflows to orchestrate the
services that process the images let's
have a look
okay before running the demo let's look
at the architecture diagram
first we have end users saving some
images to an input bucket
once the image is saved this generates
an event and this event goes to a filter
cloud run service
now this event
is routed using eventx cloud storage
trigger
now the filter service will receive the
image and it will use vision api to
determine if if it's a safe image or not
if the image is saved then the filter
starts a workflow execution
this workflow execution called image
processing will call a number of cloud
functions
the first cloud function is called
labeler
a labeler will receive the image and
again it will use vision api to extract
the labels out of the image and it will
save them to an output bucket
then workflows will call a resizercloud
function this will take the image and
resize into 400 by 400 and save it to
the footpocket as well
and then there will be another function
called watermarker that will receive the
labels from the first function and it
will also receive the resize image
and it will add a watermark
using the labels on the resize image and
then it will save it to the output
bucket
um as you can see these are three
separate functions but they're
orchestrated together using workflows
so how do you set something like this uh
we'll take a look but before i show you
the code and the setup
all of the code is on github and all the
instructions are github so feel free to
check it out yourself as well
now first let's take a look at what we
need to do
so this is the github page
and before you you begin you need to set
up the project id you need to enable the
apis that we need with event arc and
workflows and others
then we need to pick a region and we
need to set our cloud run region and our
event our location to that region
and then we need to configure some
service accounts uh because we're gonna
use them um in
event arc uh triggers
uh so we want to make sure that we have
a service account with event arc event
receiver role
and we also need a pub sub publisher
role for the cloud storage trigger and
we also want to make sure that our pub
sub service account has the service
account account token creator role
now once we have all of those and i
already set all this
we need to create a storage buckets for
our images so we create one bucket for
the
input images and another bucket for
output images so this is where the
images will be saved
by the users and this is where the
the processing will happen and the
output images will be saved as well
all right then we can start deploying
our services if you remember
we had three three cloud functions water
marker resizer and labeler that are
orchestrated together in a workflow uh
so let's look at watermark first
watermarker it's a c-sharp
function but it can be in any language
and to look at the code quickly
what it does is that first
we
read the bucket
name as an environment variable this is
the output bucket where we're going to
save the image once we process it
then we receive http request in this
method
and from the http request we extract a
couple of things first we extract the
bucket and the file information so we
can download the image
and then we also extract the labels that
will be passed in by workflows and we're
going to use these labels to add a
watermark
then we download the image from the
bucket
then in this piece of code we use an
image processing library to
use the labels and add a watermark on
top of the image
and then finally we save the image with
the watermarks to the output bucket
all right
now
to deploy this
service we just use gcloud deploy
we specify the runtime as.net 3 we make
sure that
this is a http triggered
function and we also pass in the mr
variable uh for the bucket so that this
the function knows how to save where to
save the image
so once this is deployed we can move on
to resizer resizer is very similar to
the previous water marker but instead of
adding a watermark it resizes and we
deploy it pretty much the same way
you can check out the code if you like
and then labeler is again very similar
function instead of
resizing the the image it extracts the
labels out of the image and it uses
vision api to do that so if we take a
look at the code quickly you can see
that the labeler will receive the bucket
and file information
then it will call this extra labels
async method with the storage url of the
image and if you look at this method it
basically uses the vision api uh client
to encode the detect labels async to
extract the labels then we order the
labels by
score and and we return
them in a list that we use
so once we return the labels
what we do is that we first save these
labels in a text file to the output
bucket
and then we also extract the top three
of these labels and return them as as
http response data and we're going to
use this from workforce as well
okay so that's that's labeler and now we
need to put these into an orchestration
and we do that with workflows
um and to define the workflow we create
a workflow.yaml file and then we'll
define what happens in that yaml file so
let's take a look at that quickly here
so in workflow yaml file first it
receives
some arguments
this will be coming from our cloud run
service that i'm going to show you next
and in these agreements we have the
information about the bucket and the
file and we also pass in the urls
or our
our services
because we don't want to hard code these
urls of these functions so instead we
pass them in as arguments
then we have our steps in the first
steps we log
our bucket and file information just to
make sure that we are on the right track
then in the label step we make a call to
the labeler url which is the url of the
labeler function
and we pass in the bucket and file and
then
this calls the
labeler function and then we get the
response from the function and save it
to label response
variable
then we do the same with resize step so
in the resize that we just call the
resizer and capture the response and
resize response
then in watermark
step we call the water marker but we
pass in the bucket and file information
from the resize step
this is because
we want to add the at the watermark
for the resize image right
so because of that we pass in the resize
images bucket and file information and
we also pass in the labels
from the label response because these
are the labels that we extracted from
the label function so we are passing
them in as well and the watermark will
use those labels to add the watermark
and then in the final step
we return the http status code from all
the steps just to make sure that our
workflow
completed successfully
okay so that's workflow and to deploy
our workflow um
all we need to do is just use gcloud
workflows deploy so let's just copy this
and go back here
and deploy our workflow
so this will look at our workflow.yaml
and now it's deploying our workflow
which is very quick as you can see
great now the next step is the filter
function so if you go back to our
architecture diagram we deployed our
functions we deployed our workflows now
we need to deploy the filter cloud run
service and we need to make sure that
it's connected to cloud storage events
using a cloud storage trigger
now to deploy the filter uh this is a
cloud run service so it's a we need a
docker file and we need to build and
push the image so that's what we are
doing here and then we also deploy the
cloud run service using g cloud run
deploy
and point to our image and pass in some
environment variables
these variables like the project id
region workflow name these are the
um these are the this is the information
needed for the workflow uh but we are
also passing in the urls or our
functions the labeler url the resizer
url
that way we don't need to hardcode them
in our workflow
now this i already did this
uh but now um we need to connect cloud
run service to cloud storage events and
we do that with triggers in event arc so
we create a trigger name
and then we just create a trigger
with this command here we are saying
that you know
this trigger connects
this cloud run service in this region
and it's filtering these events
these events as you can see it's the
cloud storage object finalize event this
is the event that gets triggered when
you save a file and we're also filtering
on the bucket right so let's copy this
as well
and go back here and
create our trigger
so this will create the event arc
trigger
and now everything is pretty much set
you know we have our workflow we have
our cloud run we have our trigger so now
to test we need to drop an image and see
what happens so let's make sure that our
um
our trigger
is
created yeah it's created and if i do
gcloud
you can
add
triggers list
we can see that the trigger is up and
running now to test this out
let's go to our cloud storage bucket and
you can see that i have an
input bucket so let's upload a couple of
pictures here so i will upload one
picture of myself and then i'll upload
another
beach kind of picture
so let's upload these and now this
starts up the whole chain
and if we go to the output bucket we
should start seeing some images so now i
will wait a little bit
so you can see that we have some labels
for the first picture so if you click on
the labels and look at the actual file
these are the labels that were extracted
from my picture
now the next one we see is the the
picture that's resized this is the
400 to 400 picture so it's resize to 400
400
and finally the third picture
is the resize image with the watermark
and the watermark is just the
top three labels from the image
and the just to show the other image as
well if you look at the beach um you see
that it has water color and sky as the
as the watermark
so this concludes the demo uh i hope you
enjoyed it thanks very much
thank you miche
it is great to see our products work
together to help customers connect the
cloud with less code of course
today we've discussed what we have to
offer in our orchestration in serverless
products our customer vivint has used
this to accelerate time to value
and even shown a demo that you can try
yourself via the github link that meche
have provided
to gain experience with the concepts
to learn even more there are several
other sessions
that can that can teach you about other
related serverless technology and of
course please visit us at
cloud.google.com
thank you again for spending us time
today i hope you enjoyed it as much as
we have